Avenue des prés seola proposición next
generation you de la cabeza en news
evolve our president OPA new report
mulligan on the map are realities actual
present not appear and if I collect if
the preload ibadallah nuova pen say doc
de ba and fe sanitaire Mesa madness Ian
defeat Economic Association president
Evancho to accomplish economy second
apart ready for endoscopy a neutral in a
sector not a killer or c difficile AMA
trizzie la Ponte me
Eliquis de la Chris Milan player de la
Chris le at the nominal factor a
particularly la structured la tarde upon
dos menos economy so no soap a thermal
epidermis to shape Oliver's committal
Espanola France Jiangsu fair economic mo
mezzo CDP depend on de turismo
DP avec de marsay de capital affable
Judah paid on a discreet ready roland
deschain developer open
Internacional de anza
Sacopee Donley merci de travail so noisy
situation - difficile a certain sector
from la mobility l'Automobile will
attack still suffered priests at Xavier
- table set apart asymmetric the
cephalic trees before Italy capacity
divergent visit a member sudeerneer our
economy unclear Sinan adjacent Padma
near determine a novel on the divergence
significative
dollar gross economic dizzy tomorrow the
distortion Donna Marshall unique it is
inequality social this disturbs water
you know happen no papa solo permit to
Harrisons Eden Oprah do not renew
moombas wandamae unique key function
avec une you know Priscilla conversions
aunt Elyssa tomorrow suppose la créme
repositionable poker player a sitter see
up often all this leads us to the
Commission's proposal which I have just
presented to the members of the European
Parliament this response is meant to
deal with the present crisis once
preparing the future a future that
reinforces the European Union as a whole
and each and every member state indeed
the current crisis is also an
opportunity you know the emphasis that
my commission has put on the green and
digital transition and these transitions
are even more important for the future
and at the same time we must ensure that
the transition to a climate neutral
economy leaves nobody behind next
generation EU will therefore multiply
the funding for the just transition fund
and the crisis has also taught us that
the importance of strengthening
resilience in all its dimensions for
example the health the social the
economic achieving all this can only be
done by raising our game to a completely
new level by being bold and extremely
focused at the same time the aim must be
to invest together in our common good we
will be bold by raising unprecedented
amounts of funding at European level we
will be focused by channeling the
funding to the new priorities that will
shape the future and to achieve this
we're setting up next generation EU
worth 750 billion euro together with a
core mff of
1.1 trillion this sums up to one point
eight five trillion euro
in today's proposal we will use the bulk
of this money to help member states
recover from the crisis and build up
their long-term resilience capacity
- we appoint for Daha of invested shown
under a form leading Eyenga better than
the syrup Asia semester bond - weapon is
guns claw of wounds or irritating as
directed the Nagas patient Green Deal
only digital is a honker again since he
left an Sanda program it cozy on smitten
the own metal bond shade and 30 trees up
to feed on so I am not really
Indian I'm Harrison Petrovna startin in
Hawai Ian Villegas own Antonia Mangano /
- Osteria Havasu startin field manager
said stuffy unliquidated well next year
doesn't animators cook this free drink
no 20 recapitalize even of an startin of
an hi mission marked students who can
invite early allows the craziest
decisions of which takes an industry and
industry and via trip from sketched out
emotion next generation you vote decent
for Harmon and Shupe kim also dream
Hatton's decreased for album deferred
does fear in guns our oppa by own son
gesundheit system knife by son wilson he
get us national on the capacitate ins on
a now from the quality would decrease
infested kite I know it's programs all
and stab I have in these inciting had
year of her Stanton revisionist whole
karateka fortunes and wisdom made
excellent business after non-business
Afghani no hope at Siham when they serve
on the horizon Europe of techno Stockton
permission International on combines I'm
again when via deserve a Township and
trees in English become Khan this being
very understood some films or founder of
the invested in bacon on films on a pan
and Africa's of a partner in delivering
weight
first Adam we need to be very resolute
in our response to this crisis because
our citizens and businesses have acute
and urgent needs
but we must do it in such a way that we
prepare for the future and this is why
thanks to the focus of next generation
EU and together with a baseline MFF 60%
so more than half of our investments
will go to modern policies over the next
seven years moreover in preparing the
future we must also pay attention to the
current difficult financial and
budgetary situation of many member
states therefore the funding will be
raised through loans many of which will
have very long term maturities and will
be paid back thanks to new own resources
through the next European budget these
new own resources would be levied for
example through the emission trading
system through a new carbon board
adjustment mechanism a levy on big
companies that benefit most from the
single market on single-use plastic and
through a digital text based on oacd
work this would allow Member States to
contribute to the next European budget
at the same level they currently do
allow me to stress that next generation
EU will in any case be strictly time
limited and as extraordinary as the
current crisis the proposal is on the
table it stems from intense work by the
Commission and numerous contacts with my
counterparts in the Member States and
the other European institutions we need
to reach an agreement between the
European Council and the European
Parliament as soon as possible to allow
time for the necessary national
ratifications moreover I hear the calls
for action even before the end of this
year I understand an I support these
calls and this is why we are also
proposing an immediate reinforcement of
the current mff and 2020
budget to top-up cohesion spending bring
forward recapitalization support and
funding for external action in
particular for the Western Balkan I will
work without rest with my colleagues in
the European Council and the European
Parliament to come in to an agreement as
quickly as possible on all these
proposals we are at a defining moment
for the European Union but I'm confident
the past weeks have shown that there is
a growing awareness of the need to
invest together and the European common
good and to do this by laying the
foundations for the well-being of
Europe's next generation and I always
think whether is it will there is a way
thank you thank you very much we will
now move to your questions and I would
just like to remind you that we have
today interpretation from English French
German Italian and Spanish so you can
ask your questions in those languages
and I would like to start with bernardo
de miguel bernardo if you press the
speak button
there are other ways could you prove at
least we don't speak this proposal today
could be the beginning for a translator
unum for rather in the South is the
first step to euro bonds
this is a completely new concept and a
new step forward by purpose we were
convinced that the best instrument we
can choose to get rid of the old
prejudices and the old divisions is the
European budget because the European
budget is in place it trust is it
trusted it is trusted by everyone
it is very transparent it has clear
rules and it is filled with programs
that have proven the quality over time
and therefore I think it's for all of us
now important to really give it a new
start and a new beginning to step
forward with this big endeavor of next
generation EU and I'm confident that
we'll make it I would now like to past
afford to Lotte mated a lot I press
speak
I mean yes we can hear you Lottie hello
yes we can hear you go ahead okay you
can hear me yes okay Thank You mrs.
president when we look at your proposal
today it's very very far away from where
I'm from TV to Denmark so I'm asking on
behalf of The Frugal for its very a long
way apart from where what the frugal
fall wants both on the size of the
budget but also on on how many how much
money you are giving as grants so so how
will how do you plan to get the frugal
fall on board well I have very well
studied the proposal of the frugal for
indeed and if I look at what they are
asking for is a modernised European
budget I told you that this budget is
60%
modern policies which is completely new
they are asking for front-loading
temporarily chopping I'm just reading
from the paper so we have this next
generation you as front-loaded and
temporary in place they are asking
rightly so to composition of expenditure
proportionate to our strategic
priorities I share that and therefore I
think that we take the grants and ask or
link them to the European semester in a
way that the member states come forward
present their national recovery plans
and they are combined with the European
semester gives a lot of confidence that
it's our common European policies that
we will be able to put in place through
investment and reforms and the overall
package for example the allocation of
the money through these national
have we plans in the recovery facility
will be decided together with a working
group from the council so I wanted to
make very clear that this is a common
endeavor to invest in the future to
stress our priorities and if I look at
other topics that are important for the
frugal force research and innovation
enhance resilience in the health sector
both are fulfilled in this proposal
climate growth and Digital Agenda is
fulfilled in this proposal not leading
to any mutual izing of debt is here in
The Frugal for paper and this is the
case as I said already but I'm happy to
explain that again so if you look at the
borrowing mechanism that is the basis
for next generation EU the guarantees by
the member states are in relation to the
typical share each member state gives as
a percentage to the European budget so
here very clear the rules of the
European budget and the fact that the
grants are channeled through the
European budget shows that trusted
European programs are underlying the
expense of or the the the provision of
grants and also the the paying back
period goes of course with the keys we
have for the European budget so there is
for the Member States a very clear
control on what share is theirs what the
guarantees or payback mechanism is
concerned and on the other hand we have
found a mechanism that in the at most
crisis we have at the moment being is
generating enough common money that we
can bring forward the European level by
this so of course there will be
discussions and debates now in Council
and the European Parliament
I must say I spent the last weeks this
was very important work because of
course I reached out a lot to the member
states all heads of state and government
to our parliamentarians in the European
Parliament
so to listen a lot to what their focus
our ample emphasis is because in the
very end I think it is important for the
Commission to come forward with the own
proposal but also to have it in a wise
form so that everyone can start working
on it in a constructive manner next
person next question if I may
the first one is on possible enhanced
cooperation by a Coalition of the
Willing
if the proposal doesn't pass in the
European Council it's been floated by
some parameters do you think that it
would be feasible or not and the second
one it's a Technical College but I have
to ask it because it's not clear how
much money of the 7 750 billion euros
will go to Italy will they be 153 or 173
thank you so much
Tommaso on your latter question these
figures will be made public officially
tomorrow and there will be a specific
series of press conferences related to
the programs with pre allocated amount
so you will get the final confirmed
information officially on that day I
think it is now very important I think
it's very important that we now focus on
this proposal we should not forget that
we are in a deep crisis and we haven't
seen the end of the crisis so far so
things are getting more and more serious
and therefore we should all focus all 27
and the European Parliament
this proposal you know I would always
argue towards within discussion for
example with a frugal foe but with all
27 member states that the experience we
made together in the European Union is
that none of our member states would be
at this level of prosperity and social
security if it were not for our single
market and if we're not if it were not
for our European Union so we all share
by contributing to the European programs
but we get out of it way more and I
think for any of the Member State not
only the frugal force but for any of the
Member States it's very clear if you
have companies that have supplier
companies in other parts of the European
Union and they get into economic
difficulties it will hamper your own
national companies or your own national
economy because the single market is so
deepened and we are so interdependent
which is good this is the strength of
the single market that it is it pays off
to invest in this single market we can
and have developed together rules how we
invest so this is also a proven
instrument in the in the European budget
we are using the European semester and I
think this combination of recovery plans
that are tailored or tailor-made to the
situation in the Member State a creation
recovery plan will be different than a
Portuguese one a Swedish recovery plan
will be different to a Romanian one but
this combined with our European
priorities is a an an ideal opportunity
not only to repair from to repair the
damages of the crisis but also to step
forward and modernizing our single
market and pushing forward our European
priorities and I think every member
state made this experience that they are
thanks God in this union growing and beg
better because of the union because of
the single market so this is in my eyes
very convincing to invest in the single
market Joseon completes us with a call
that please drizzle over Pia
James yeah appear sure confetti see
responsibility community become very
format no no luck fees may pass Kanu's
Orestes beaucoup de motto no to lose on
the lam they still don't attend the
problem who knows or found only two
example the shows more climatic
numeric suppose we merged and Piazza
knew own resources indeed the situation
has changed it is up to the Member
States to discuss and to decide but we
see now that we all understand that the
crisis is so huge that we have to take
unusual steps to overcome the crisis and
to get out stronger from the crisis this
is raising money at the market and the
idea behind the own Europe sources is
twofold once these are all new resources
that do not tax the individual but are
promoting our main priorities and are
going into a political field that is
important for us for example the digital
text that says if you are making a lot
of profit in the European market which
is fine you should also contribute to
our not only market but our social
security system by paying taxes this is
one part the emission trading system
here indeed there will certainly be
discussions I want to make clear that
we're not talking about revenues from
the emission trading systems that are
already in place but we are talking
about potential future revenues for
example with the maritime or aviation
sector so additional ETS resources that
could be used to ease the repayment of
next generation EU and therefore it's a
completely new situation to decide for
the Member States how to move forward
that we have to pay back what we raise
now at the market is obvious and
therefore I think to introduce all new
resources new own resources is the right
and wise step forward also to clarify
the situation for the future I think
we've had a poetic moment during the
press conference I think that what
Christians be meant by I saw is actually
the Treasury function
of a member state which as you know
manages the fine raises funds and
actually then manages them we like
poetic moments through our press
conferences I think this question was a
bit more political and technical so
would you please yeah so is this a first
step in creating a Treasury function as
those that exist in the member states
that is to say an institution that
permanently borrows money on the markets
and allocate enough suppose at least
your avec la mama poetic this is
language barrier and three so I'll
answer to your question here the answer
is no because we have to be very clear
this is one of and this is exceptional
so I and therefore the answer is clear
in the way you wanted to ask me Thank
You president we now move to david
national and political
David you are on but we cannot hear you
yes good thank you very much president
thanks for taking the time with us I
wonder if you could talk to us given the
speed that you've said it's necessary
and given how we know these negotiations
going to be so difficult with the heads
of state and government are there
aspects of this plan that are negotiable
is there a plan B if it looks like
fundamental disagreement about
mutualization of debt we heard your take
on this but for for those governments
who feel that their citizens are not
ready to borrow a euro that will then be
deployed in other member states and be
on the hook for paying back any more
than is used within their own borders is
there a plan B are there aspects of this
that are negotiable
well first of all the general concept so
the general concept that on top of the
MFF we use an increased own resources
ceiling that is the guarantees by the
Member States to raise money on the
capital market and to channel this
through the European budget is accepted
the discussion is about the size and the
discussion is about grants and loans or
grants or loans but the general
principle to use the Headroom for
raising money on the market has been
discussed and we have been tasked as a
commission to work on that model so
therefore I think especially in this
exceptional situation where we really
need a clear and strong and united
answer to this to this crisis this was
and is a big step forward
I used of course the last week's that we
created by discussion and discussing a
lot with the European Parliament and the
Member States a very establishing a very
sound legal basis for this construction
so as I said the debate goes about the
size that is raised at the market and
what is loans what part is loans what
part is grants or do we have
only grants or only loans that will have
to be discussed and I think it's
positive that we are now starting to
work with the solution it will change in
any negotiation a concept is partly
changed but I'm deeply convinced that is
the sound answer we should give it gives
us an M FF a European budget that is
urgently needed and it gives us an
answer to the acute crisis Griselda you
have the floor you are a power
voila
mutant akuto
Griselda total pomelos Moga Zelda donk
news alone Percy Tom van Gartner
official speak
Turkish cotton visitor I'm sorry we we
did not hear the beginning of your
question could you start over
[Music]
[Applause]
pretend loans on sutures visitor
Portland is that a politician political
compromise it won't be obtained if he
commissioned a Granik targets double of
exactly she under went then at the
cognitive onion by the normal finance or
started by the moment in anthem for the
nation's India but beginning of August
lon despite a forest
Suba and Walton visit Xena and in favor
of Oaxaca bleep then the vision of test
their mettle Castillo finance harm
amount Blake in this appraiser for the
millage start and the dotted Suzanne
active in suit scientist a design
against Egypt after blasting they meet
each tartan the the denpa is fed up
Cynthia Zia and the enforce luckily
their intimate of the Matus luck that's
bling tones about sodium's fight and
came out thus yes this go fart on MIT
[ __ ] at sushi so undetected eater the
sushi sent all those artists and these
are who note fiendish on dear Africa and
what out decrease again Sukhram the
sinusoids nationalist Hema
there's recovery and resilience facility
as their national and plenary for
Galician we're not done our patient
semester invested shown on
performin after soufiane London digital
set example of a patient outside st i'm
english i'm sue shows two hidden truths
in our program it's washed out in
funding vivisun that's the absolute no
20 cent on decrease of survive in all a
Bosch darker after and resilience in in
florida consuming fill in Anakapalle
villain n does is this solvency
instrument as an instrument does uber
europe asia invested jones bump s filmin
mo glitched but in private sector
privado invested shown in capital after
Stockman
when Z admitted statins and the diesel
McLeish tightest financial condition so
not sunken the undramatic startin our
the strategic investment facility as an
instrumented us in there lag is in
enshrined and truly forgotten Anna first
outcome for to name diameter up English
tight from Einstein global sulla
forgotten which message talk as vivid as
index is again have above the first
outcome fun become different and shines
and um the no patient market so more
energy and keep in and bas B horizon
Europe the country's
excellence program for the for Jean
business often innovation order Erasmus
understood enter non-student in the
Chiappa
I saw a parent of a PUD uncon home notes
by by phillotson n I does most of Anna
basses their sutures design then norm
IRA or patient outside is Anne's ich ein
susses
the [ __ ] a creditor is Stan ina Mukesh
catfish tartan food is rustic Avera she
did to it by the okay sure
onion or young fish onions to become and
a fogger DD method starting convenient
comedian at CERN and vida off pal plane
does stay up of decline or a child
the in via in next-generation you
unleashed her
all right we are going to try grizzled
one last time twizzle develop all Nazish
well Chris alleged easily Miriam
Technica vector a vector mijo episode on
the lead character radio radically new
question super Madonna president la
première whose avidly Levitas important
proposition poo diggery
old media on the mill that problemo
so to your to your first question of the
speed I think it is in our all common
interest and no member state has not
been hit by the crisis that we're fast
with this I know there is a process to
manage so we need unanimity in council
and then we need to convince national
parliaments to ratify this needs
and on in their own respective country
on the other hand we have the common
European priorities that are laid on the
European semester and I mentioned them
several times and we will have a
decision after the negotiations that are
typical that is taken not only by the
Commission but also by Council so you
have a sound and wise system that
balances the different interests in the
common European interests and I think
it's also an opportunity to bring
forward our knowledge about how do we
wanna move forward as a European Union
what is necessary to be strong to be
prosperous to be sustainable in our
economies we now move to sound Flemming
you mentioned particularly on the
corporate levy tax on big companies that
benefit from the single market it sounds
a little bit like the CCC TV but
obviously not entirely like that I
wonder if you give us a little bit more
detail as to what actually tax would
thank you you broke off a bit but I
think we got the gist of your of your
questions yes and yeah so the indeed
there are three options to pay back my
favorite is increased new owned
resources or in the new next use me in
the next mff with a long period till 2
t58 you can balance between increased
contributions or reduced programs so
these are the three options that are out
there for payback so you can imagine I
think it's in the common European
interest to build up new own resources
in a way that we have a stable path to
pay back these own new resources so on
the on the taxes themselves in detail I
think we'll have further press
conferences during the next days so you
might want to elaborate that there in
fact following this press conference we
will have another press conference with
budget commissioner in therefore it
would be to ask him we now move to
a permanent contact Medina start
something evil chefs visit initial
meeting frugal for unjust mirtha then an
intensive of vegetables - of in on-site
part then a skink naturally snitch known
before
it's not flour - for our concert in
London's after its Bussieres a
vegetation account solely directly
Shabazz's had sustained but a scone
concept Irish tight had sustained as a
confidence with us from SUNY ins on only
have as their feet silence a figures
pleasure after half event so this court
Ian deviates from rusty program and
legal associate a sweet texture vivid a
scared hours cables odors is concealed
invested indeed Zukunft of a good
invasion of done the outs capacities in
so far a bishop suits in my villa mid
iron starts on Peggy wrong chefs on
ultimate in through before deliver
Gershwin
it means felish clavo deformer heart
isn't via focus Ian D for behind him
elixir of the frugal form and I truly
had a fan underneath which tartan and
reformed fund for behind me gave
montez's furnish an opening so does this
year all fishermen had on the whole
patient on yonder's and of course he
toboggan it ate after I turn and posit
shown in my V don't want em - than anger
Minds ambition a phone offended versus
tema and get her battered son by feel I
said cans feel a team of team Trish
aunty go home we Emma but I am for
handling MIT ihnen cop never talked
advert on their 400-foot Isaac's first
enter tied after Steve Rubell fourth
select millionth or more about to come
up a meter feel I'm going for on a bus
come under meat which start in the
gunship it see for sure first along have
discovered some some 400 possesses a
special English meter to offender if you
must earn a good balance fintan does via
Jesus called construct the sphere that
Rize anger Mason next generation in you
yet
after by understand that's where an
illusion fintan V fear grants as we fit
sutures on Visa credit unions and that's
why I need cattle over here stain vivia
Skelton vestian warned and reminds I'm a
patient in tracer on Revere the ballast
on auscultation condensation denied
cinema theater
I'll tell us yours you have the floor
Madam President I think that there is a
critical mass of what can work and what
cannot work in a plan like this and
you're proposing a ratio of two to one
grants versus loans you have mentioned
that this is apt for negotiation after
which point do you think that the aims
the targets of your plan will be
realized if this ratio changes how low
can we go from either side
I could imagine this for the leaders but
you must give a let's say a technical
assumption on what works and what
doesn't work concerning this ratio
Thanks for me was important to put
forward the color
the Commission's proposal which has to
be ambitious but realistic and plausible
and that's what we've done today so I'm
the wrong person to ask because I am
convinced that this is the the ratio we
should have and this is the amount that
is needed so if we look at our needs
assessment it shows that there is the
need out there not only for the European
level also for the Member States also
for the private level but there's a huge
need out there an investment gap that we
have a financing gap that we have in the
Member States and an equity problem that
we have in many companies so this is
well calibrated we have a sound
assessment that was the basis for coming
to the solution of five hundred grands
and 250 loans at the very end which we
saw as our responsibility on the
European level including the
responsibility of the Member States and
the private level equally I think you
will take a one last question from
Samuel
we've also madhumatl did we consume
nearly right Shawn if you also getting
just on the default on the wrong one
more
can I create opposites from the
controller consultant from the safety
sees a green piece has to Mortimer Club
opposition even when I couldn't make
money palette on they me keep a this
refers all-star concentration areas of
expertise from the natural tentacle wvf
soprano the mechanism Eclair keep
organized only principal is it amongst
traffic there's activity that automobile
Python is a common tell us if I could do
so much on top of almost a political New
York removed upgrade so ID few Melissa
Bachman songs a little more post corner
use yes so first of all we have a very
clearly detailed out that this
investment through the next-generation
EU has to be aligned with our European
priorities and I repeat them it is the
European Green Deal and it is the
digitization and it is resilience we
have decided that 25% of the whole
budget and therefore the overall budget
will be streamlined to the European
Green Deal and very clearly put down
that whatever we do it should not do
harm to our goal to be climate neutral
in 2050 the same goes for the
digitization extremely needed I think
it's self-explanatory because we needed
or we saw how much we need the
digitization during the crisis and there
will be a very clear focus a very clear
emphasis on it it's in our common
European interest and it's an absolute
must to develop our single market in a
way that it will be resilient also in
future
I think that the post corona world
will put way more emphasis on the
possibilities the digitisation gives us
and will put more emphasis on what I
call a competitive sustainability
because we've seen how important it is
to have a certain level of strategic
autonomy without renouncing to global
trade which is enormously important we
an open society and we an open economy
but we will be more mindful with the
supply chains and the use of material
then we were before Corona
I am deeply convinced that we will have
to learn and it's our to our benefit to
go way more in a circular economy a
circular economy that once takes
resources but then learns and this is
fascinating to see when it when you have
the hallmarks or the examples for it
how to recycle the product over and over
and over we will go way more to an
economy that is services based than
product based and we will keep in mind
that this competitive sustainability
that was visible also that was visible
also during the corona crisis how
dependent we are on that that this will
be developed so we will be we will have
a new normal after Corona thank you very
much we have now come to the end of this
press conference you have a second
opportunity to ask questions with the
press conference which will start in
10-15 minutes with Commissioner Hahn I
therefore recommend that you stay
connected it will take a bit of time
before the next press conference starts
but we'll be using the same same link
thank you again